I'm selling things that don't exist
you believe there are seven core
principles to pitching yeah and I like
to use the word principle instead of
rules because uh truth is like
I mean you can see in the past like 15
years in the past three years in terms
of how things have worked just how
things technology interactions the way
we engage with content that changes all
the time
but the core principles behind how
things function those never change so I
like to work with principals yeah but I
I've identified
seven that I think are just sort of true
and consistent they're the same today as
they were back in Shakespeare's time
period of how do you pitch a story idea
and get the thing rolling well it looks
like the first one is selling yes okay I
think sales has a really negative word
or connotation I should say to it but um
you have to sell yourself if you want to
pitch your idea
um we talked about it before you can you
can write a great script but if it just
sits on your desktop on your laptop like
No One's Gonna see it you need to be
able to pitch yourself you need to be
able to pitch why it's worth reading you
need to get it to the right people not
get it to everybody not do a mass email
but um find the right people the right
companies that would resonate with it
and sell yourself and sell your idea
number two pitching is listening
pitching is listening yes
um
I most of my pitch meetings because I
pitch two you know I'm pitching business
to business so I'm pitching
a business opportunity of how can we get
a film made how can we get a TV series
made in order for me to get that order
out of the client I need to listen to
what they want they need to tell me
um either they need to tell me or I need
to do the research and find out what is
it that they need what are they looking
for what is their company on the hunt
for and I have to Showcase why we're the
best ones to deliver it and if you're
pitching your ideas uh
your stack of of 100 pages of script
like that doesn't change in the middle
of that meeting but how you talk about
it can so if um you're dealing with a
client and they start presenting or
discussing or describing content in a
specific way listening to that listening
to how they talk about content listening
to what it is that they really need is
your way to transition a meeting into an
opportunity for yourself so yeah it's
people will tell you exactly what they
need they'll tell you exactly what they
want and there's no shortage of
information out there in terms of being
able to at least get a pretty solid idea
of how to position yourself what if
they're so nervous that they can't
listen because they're so worried about
will this turn out do they like my work
whatever it is okay it's it's it can be
nerve-wracking in a sense look I would
say this actually it can be
nerve-wracking when you're not used to
it
um it can be nerve-wracking when you
have built this idea of what pitching
must be like versus how it actually is I
think most people Envision uh you know
an Entourage scary boardroom situation
of you know six seven eight expensive
suit people staring at you with like
cold faces and um I'm not saying I
haven't had that experience but like for
the most part pitching is actually
pretty easy going
you're meeting somebody over coffee
you're having just a quick chat over a
zoom or you know a Google meeting
um phone call
that's how most pitching is actually
most pitching is done by email and if
you are uncomfortable
um you can take as much time as you need
to craft a good email and if you can
Target it well and you don't write it
too long you know you can actually sort
of pitch quite well that way but you
always want to make it more that look
I'm starting this idea but I'm really
here to work for you what do you need as
a company because I can deliver it and
that's sort of the opportunity to get
that feedback loop of we need XYZ and we
need writers who can work in this
capacity
and excuse me how long is too long for
an email
uh yeah they've actually done studies on
this I'm sure there's some analysis
somewhere
um but and I think there's actually like
studies about how long you should I
think it's like 27 characters for a
subject line so it can be read entirely
on an iPhone uh
but anyway that's a whole long-winded
way that's fascinating I would say like
four paragraphs of like two sentences
each is like the max for an email and
it's Gotta sort of be
you're presenting everything you've got
you know the five W's who what where
when why it's you're saying this is who
I am this is the script I have and you
got to make it as easy for your client
as possible when I'm pitching movies
they're finished movies but when I'm
pitching movies
um to buyers internationally or here in
the states like I make it as easy for
them as possible because they're busy
and it's not that they're rude it's not
that they're you know it's just that
they're busy so the easier I can make it
the better
um
you're presenting yourself you know you
want to talk about yourself it's not
don't just dive in with screenplays XYZ
this is the concept it's much more like
you know you've showcased that you've
actually like done your research and
that you're presenting yourself and by
the way you have this script too and
you'd like to start a conversation about
writing you know it's it's not like buy
this script right now it's much more
I I'm a writer I'm trying to look for uh
opportunities what you're writing I'm
sorry what you're producing is very much
in sync with what I'm writing I have a
couple of log lines I'd love to share
them with you if uh you know we can chat
sometime it's it's very casual number
three presentation matters absolutely
um
most of the deals I have secured it's
what I do in the industry I'm selling
things that don't exist I'm going into
uh a television network or working with
a VOD platform and I am selling as I
said a lot of the deals I do the
contract is literally like title to be
determined we have no idea what the
movie is we're selling that we're gonna
make a movie and sometimes it'll be like
to be determined Christmas movie or to
be determined Thriller but we don't know
what the movie is
um so in order to get that I have to
present in the best possible manner uh
what it is that I'm going to deliver
upon
um so if you are doing that so I mean
I'll create like really nice pitch decks
I'll spend a lot of time on them
um I'll I'll Source images from places
like canva or pixel or other or other
spots and they have these amazing
resources the photos you can use and you
can build presentations our whole
industry and I think in a visual minded
sense a lot of those on the creative
side in our industry are very visual
thinking so being able to express their
ideas in a visual way I think is
important
uh and they also get to do that after
doing like a personal branding website
but that's sort of the thing I guess I'm
talking about is
if if a name pops up uh in an email
um in somebody's email box like before
you hit reply you're gonna like Google
them
or is this person legit is this spam is
this this is this that and
um looking if they have a website
if they if they don't have credits
that's okay uh but it's like if they
have a website and you can see like this
is a real person and they seem to be
very professional and they seem to sort
of like be reasonable and how they're
functioning in terms of what their
expectations are yeah you will probably
reach out you don't want to lose an
opportunity
um and presentation matters in the sense
of how you dress how do you present
yourself how what is your etiquette when
you're on the phone or or via email are
you clear and do you do you express
yourself clearly or are you one of these
people who just like has really choppy
vague emails and people aren't really
sure what to make of them do you over
extend the opportunity and reach too far
too quickly
um
it's it's those are kinds of the things
about presentation matters but I think
website visual what can you do there's a
lot of that is in your own control too
and I think that's actually something
that's good
and just curious what would an example
be of overextending oh like like 9 000
emails a day or you know way too many
text messages I mean I have people who
like
send me like 15 text messages in a row
like it's like
my phone just vibrates for a good like
12 seconds and I know who it is you know
it's uh it's people like that that's a
little bit overreaching too many phone
calls but the occasional like check-in
is totally fine and you should check in
and like keep up on things but um you
know it's it's I think basic etiquette
understanding so maybe the understanding
of realizing that you're not the only
person they're working with I know it's
hard when it comes to your personal
matter or project but realizing this
person might be dealing with a hundred
emails that day yeah it's it's for sure
and look I mean 100 is a good day like I
I get way more than that and um you
can't read them all you can't read them
all so you do have to like make
decisions of like what am I gonna
actually focus on today and getting to
some of those kinds of emails that are
more like the blind cold call cold email
kind of things
it is at the bottom of the list but it
does get addressed and so that's why
it's so important like if you've got
that much time
and that much attention from somebody
you got to make sure you're you're
getting everything right that's
presentation that you've done your
research that you're presenting stuff
that actually resonates you know and
it's it's that's sort of where all that
falls into and yeah I think it's it's
really critical to remember that when
you're reaching out and I I remind
myself of this too
because like
it'll go weeks and I won't hear back
from clients and
um you know you sort of do question like
you know what what went wrong and the
truth is they're busy they're really
busy they and they have personal lives I
have a personal life I have a family you
know it's it's um that does eat into the
equation too in terms of time
number four pitching is repitching yeah
it's it's it's
um it's not like you pitch once and then
everything just falls into place it's um
you will pitch your idea at log line
stage and if you're fortunate enough to
get
um a writer for hire agreement you'll
re-pitch the ideas you put in the
treatment you'll have to repitch at
script at script stage you'll have to
once the script is acquired I have to go
pitch people I have to go pitch people
to get the project funded we have to go
pitch it to talent and explain to them
why they would want to be in this film
you would think that you know actors
would be jumping up and down to be in
movies but it's like
um sometimes they are so busy with
projects you also have to pitch like
look if you can only do seven films this
year this should be one of them and
here's why and it's it's a constant
thing when we're marketing our films
that's a pitch a trailer of a movie is a
pitch it's pitching you saying you only
have so much time this evening to watch
a television show or a movie make it
ours
Pluto TV uh Tubi TV Netflix they're
pitching you too and they're saying if
you only are going to watch content on
one platform tonight make it us that
that's the whole process of repitching
this it's not like you do it once and
it's done if you take a film like
Chinatown which just for some reason is
just constantly said is like the best
script ever written and it's like that's
not actually what it was when they
filmed the movie that's what it ended up
being in the end
um but you know at script stage that had
to get you know that had to go through a
lot of layers before it finally turned
out the other side at the end the way it
did and a lot of that also happened on
set in the editing room and just you
know uh uh concessions they had to make
in post and all that so it's it's that
sort of the thinking is that
a script is never done until the movie
is released that's sort of my view of it
number five pitching is a slow process
yes it's a very slow process it does not
happen overnight I'm I'm talking to
clients it's right now it's March 2023
when we're filming this I'm pitching
clients you know uh uh 18 months in
advance in the sense of I'm trying to to
guarantee slates that are next year or
even early 2025.
um it's it's a slow process in the sense
of
you may have to pitch a client and then
repitch them and then repitch them and
then repitch them market after market
quarter after court quarter I try to get
um usually quarterly calls or like you
know six month calls with some of my key
clients just to keep them up to speed of
what we're doing and what we can bring
to the table
um and yeah we are constantly
representing sometimes the same stuff in
those meetings uh I would say on average
like to get a movie like a low budget
movie anything under two and a half
million
um
that can be
kind of quick you could do that maybe in
six months like concept to green light
but if you're talking television like a
whole series that's at least an 18-month
process if not two years and that's
planting the seed of the idea and then
like this is why I always Focus so much
on principles over Trends because there
are Trends there are things that are
like super popular today and then you'll
get a flood of emails from writers who
like I stayed up all night and wrote
this movie because this is like the hot
new thing and it's like it's gonna take
like six months to get this funded shot
delivered released by that time that
trend is gone nobody cares about it
anymore so it's it's TV shows that come
out and they're extremely like relevant
or everyone's talking about it they were
just really good quality programs but
they were being developed you know 18
months two years uh beforehand I mean
Queen's Gambit is like the best example
I don't know the exact dates of that one
but I want to say it was like the 90s
the early like they started they
greenlit I'm sorry they acquired the
book rights before the lead actress was
even born like that's how long that was
in that development hell process it's a
very slow process and the truth is you
got to keep a lot of pots boiling at
once on the back burner you know if I'm
dealing with a client and they need six
films this year I may have 18 to 20
projects we're keeping warm
because we don't know exactly which one
they're going to go with and then they
pick them very quick and then all of a
sudden you're Off to the Races but yeah
that that process in between can be a
very long drawn out time period
number six pitching is a lot like dating
yes this is this is a
I adamantly believe that business in
general is a lot like dating it's um you
use the exact same protocols you are
putting yourself out there you have kind
of a clear understanding of what you're
trying to achieve and there's no exact
one way to get from beginning to end so
to speak you do have to presentation
matters you do have to sort of pitch and
present who you are you have to sort of
showcase why you're worth dating uh you
have to bring all that to the table you
have to be willing to go out and accept
that some people are going to say no and
they were going to say no no matter what
you said you're just not compatible the
chemistry isn't right and then the whole
process of how do you communicate
um you know you don't want to over
communicate you don't want to write too
many crazy emails you don't want to text
too much you don't want to call
inappropriate numbers of times or leave
50 voicemails all of those little sort
of nuances I think are just true of
human behavior in general you there's
sort of a social understanding of
this is an acceptable mode of how we're
communicating uh and then there's kind
of a a totally Unwritten line that you
sort of instinctually know you shouldn't
cross but unfortunately a few people do
and uh that's sort of where that all
comes from so if we took that analogy
and said well okay don't talk about your
ex on the first date for like over an
hour
what would be the same thing for a
writer maybe don't talk about deals that
fell through and trash a studio or what
would be the same type of thing because
that's an equal turn off you know yeah I
would say just in general
don't talk anybody like and and
like just
I'm not even gonna say like it's okay if
like the other person brings it up like
just don't don't be that person be
professional it's okay that you have a
script that you know was with another
client and maybe they optioned it and
then nothing happened with it that
happens and that does not make it like a
tarnished property
um
you can you can speak openly but you
don't have to like you know you don't
want to trash talk people and and fall
into that game uh that just because the
the question always then ends up being
like well if things don't work out with
us what are you going to say about us
behind our backs you know so it's like
it kind of makes people kind of want to
say I don't know if I really want to
bring this writer in because uh
they what are they going to say if like
if if they write a script for us and we
pay them and then like all of a sudden
the network says no to the project and
they get the rights to the script back
they've been paid but um you know these
things happen and so yeah if you have
writers who sort of like you know trash
talk people that does happen
um so it's those kinds of things it's
just again it's like it's it's basic
social skills basic etiquette
number seven relationships are
everything yes relationships
um really fuel the business
uh and that's I think the most
challenging at first it feels the most
challenging I would say if you're new to
the industry
um
regardless of what age you are it's it's
just uh if you're new to the industry it
feels like you know nobody and I would
say like during the pandemic
this was so powerfully understood
because those of us who've been in the
industry long enough you know
10 years 15 years who have real clients
that we know and can reach out to
we were fine during the pandemic we
could communicate we should just reach
out and shoot an email or a call and it
was fine but if you didn't have those
connections that was such a tough time
period and it really
kind of created this big gap and I know
a lot of younger people who are kind of
maybe a year or two behind where they
could be because of the pandemic but um
where do you meet connections and how do
you build them truth is you just start
you don't you just start one at a time
and it's okay to talk to people and meet
with people who don't seem to have
anything to do with what you do and in
truth that's where you're going to find
your Best Contacts like if you are a
writer it's great to work with other
writers and talk to other writers but at
a certain point like you also need to
meet people on the other side of the
fence who are more on the business side
and learn what they do and learn how
they function in their system so that
you can sort of find those opportunities
but it's just a slow process it's it's
not going to happen overnight and it's
something you just sort of have to make
a habit you have to make a habit of
talking to other people you have to make
a habit of communicating well presenting
yourself well all the time and it goes
back to the whole
pitching is like dating it's like
if you are single you know those
opportunities can pop up at any time so
you sort of have to always be ready for
them I guess in a sense but yeah it's
it's you need to be able to consistently
and regularly be open to the idea of
communicating with people who are in the
industry learn what they do find out how
it works in the system and if you just
kind of keep that process going and you
stay in relatively reasonable
communication with everybody over time
you'll start to find dots to connect I
know that person and they are at that
company and I can reach out to them now
and maybe when you first met that wasn't
the case but you know 12 months down the
line they got a job opportunity and now
it's an in for you that's how it works
and then once you do work together uh
and you've gotten a job or two in
whatever capacity in the industry you
just do the best work you can and Truth
is like your reputation does hold and
it's the little things that give people
a sense of who you really are so you got
to give it your all do you feel like
writers expect things to happen more
rapidly as the world has gotten so fast
and everything's instantaneous have you
noticed that or no that's yes I think in
general uh but it's it's a sense that
people have that like things just
happen way quicker than they really do
um you know that if you if you send a
script that it's going to be read that
day or the next day and it's like you
know it may take a month to get it read
uh if if there is a deal to be done
um that it's going to happen in a week
and it's like no it can take two three
months to negotiate a deal uh so it it
just draws out a lot longer on the
actual real world professional side and
so that will Ripple into buying cycles
and scripts
um but yeah I think it's it's being
realistic about time expectations is
very critical to anyone starting out in
the industry in whatever capacity